UMBRELLA!
>> I WAS JUST KIDDING, THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME ON YOUR SHOW.
>> Harris: ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TIME TO
TALK.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT A
TRANSITION POINT, WHAT HE SEES
AS SUNNIER DAYS AHEAD.
BUT NO ONE, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT, HAS DENIED THAT WHAT
IS IMMEDIATELY COMING IS AS
PAINFUL AS IT CAN GET EACH DAY.
WHAT IS FORECAST AHEAD?
30 MILLION PEOPLE PLUS OUT OF
WORK RIGHT NOW.
>> YES, THAT’S TRUE.
AND WE ARE IN A SEVERE
CONTRACTION, WHICH OF COURSE
COMES FROM THE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THE VIRUS.
IT’S NOBODY’S FAULT, IT’S JUST
THERE.
AND THE STRONG STEPS THE
PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN TO DEAL WITH
THE VIRUS, WHICH HAS PUT US
MEDICALLY, IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND A MUCH BETTER
POSITION.
THE CURVE IS FLATTENING OUT, AND
YOU SEE STATES NOW BEGINNING TO
USE OUR FEDERAL GUIDELINES, PUT
TOGETHER BY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, AS
METRICS, IF YOU WILL.
IT’S GOING TO BE DATA-DRIVEN,
HEALTH AND SAFETY IS FOR US.
BUT A LOT OF STATES ARE EITHER
BEGINNING TO OR ABOUT TO REOPEN.
THAT WILL HELP THE ECONOMY.
BUT NO, THERE IS NO QUESTION,
HARRIS, IS A DEEP, PAINFUL,
HARDSHIP-RIDDEN CONTRACTION.
IT IS NOT COMPLETED YET.
>> Harris: IS IT TOO EARLY TO
TALK ABOUT THE RECOVERY?
WHEN WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE END
WILL LOOK LIKE?
DR. FAUCI WITH THE TASK FORCE,
YOU SIT WITH HIM EVERY DAY.
IT WAS PRETTY JARRING TO HEAR
HIM USE THIS WORD ABOUT A SECOND
WAVE.
NOT POTENTIAL ANYMORE,
"INEVITABLE."
>> LOOKED, TONY FAUCI IS A
LONGTIME FRIEND.
HE’S AN EXPERT.
I THINK HE IS TAKING ACCOUNT OF
ALL THE POSSIBILITIES AND
PROBABILITIES.
THAT IS HIS JOB, AND HE DOES A
VERY GOOD JOB OF IT.
I WILL SAY THIS -- WE ARE, I
BELIEVE, BASED ON THE NUMBERS
FLATTENING OUT, MAY IS GOING TO
BE A TRANSITION MONTH FOR
REOPENING THE ECONOMY.
LET’S JUST CALL IN MAY, SPILLING
OVER INTO EARLY JUNE.
WE’VE BEEN MEETING WITH BUSINESS
PEOPLE, LARGE AND SMALL
COMPANIES, CEOs, ALMOST
EVERYBODY.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TOWARD
REOPENING.
I THINK WHEN YOU SEE THAT IT IS
A TURNING POINT.
I DON’T THINK THAT IS AN UNFAIR
WORD TO USE.
IT’S NOT UNREALISTIC TO HOPE
THIS IS A TURNING POINT.
WE HAVE VERY HIGH HOPES THAT,
GIVEN THE HUGE RESCUE PACKAGE
PUT TOGETHER BY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WITH THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE,
WE’VE ACTUALLY PUT IN THE
FEDERAL RESERVE AND THE BUDGET
STUFF, HARRIS, YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT ROUGHLY $9 TRILLION.
IT’S A REMARKABLE THING.
IT’S ABOUT CASH AND LIQUIDITY
AND SURVIVAL AND PAY RULES AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND ALL THE
REST THAT YOU’VE BEEN REPORTING
ON.
>> Harris: GOT IT.
>> LET ME GO TO THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE,
WHICH HAS BRAVELY AND BOLDLY PUT
OUT FORECASTS.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A VERY
SIGNIFICANT SNAPBACK, BEGINNING
THIS SUMMER AND INTO THE FALL.
THEY ARE SAYING THE SECOND HALF
OF THIS YEAR, REAL GDP COULD
GROW.
17-20%.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT A NEAR 3% GROWTH RATE
FOR 2021.
I BELIEVE IT ACTUALLY WILL DO
BETTER THAN THAT.
BUT I THINK JUST THERE, AND A
LOT OF PRIVATE SECTOR
FORECASTERS, HARRIS, HAVE